he's one of our favorites he's dan
please act back here on the show hire
you Dan rich I'm not in Butler's cabin
but I'll tell you what I have it on my
TV and Tiger is wet on the part three
you're exactly right okay hey on a
positive note Tony P now I think birdied
one of the par threes but he did run
down like yesterday what's the that's
something I would do you know what I did
an opening day in 1988 later on as a
team so I'd say what you know they
introduce you right you can't hear
anything old County Stadium and and the
PR director they're like okay run
because it's so loud and what do I do
rich I do a header like statement strip
on the top step and fall right on the
warning track and it was like that brown
rock stops well I'm the only guy we were
playing the Red Sox I'm standing on the
foul line look at it grunts and all the
Red Sox players are laughing at me as my
pants and my arms are covered in like
brown dirt oh star on opening day but it
wasn't blood you didn't draw oh no no no
no blood no what okay
and it's because I was about to ask you
what's the the freakiest accident you've
ever witnessed then then I would imagine
it's that or is it another one now that
was it for me opening day 1988 Space
Shuttle right up top step County Stadium
oh man fantastic all right Dan what's
the story of the first week rich I
watched a guy all spring training and I
kept thinking like of all the guys that
I've seen video tape up my world is the
pitching world I really couldn't tell
you if he's going to hit or not because
that's not my area of expertise
but what I saw in video all winter about
this guy on the mound I was like this
guy's better than my ADA this guy's
better than Tanaka this was the guy this
was the best Japanese pitcher I thought
talent that I've seen and then the guy I
saw in the Cactus League I was like what
the hell's going on with this guy like
this isn't the guy that I saw but I'll
tell you what his first start against
the ACE ultra impressive 96 to 98
touched 100 a couple of times loved his
split finger and spider he threw some
good ones he threw some not-so-good ones
but terrific Talent you know it's funny
is that's Sunday I'm on the air with Dan
O'Brien
and I made the statement like I just
don't see how anybody can be good at
Boalt in a day and age where pro sports
particularly baseball it's so
centralized on doing one or the other
and I had a hard time for 18 years
worrying about the mound I didn't see
how this guy was going to be able to do
Bolton hit and he's proven really since
then he's hit a couple of home runs he's
either he's a remarkable talent rich
that I guess a lot of people in baseball
want to see if this two-way thing can
really make it a go and through one week
I'd say it's a it's a two thumbs up
yeah and the two home runs that we just
showed on the television side of things
while you were talking one was like a
hanging 74 mile an hour breaking ball
that just just spun right there in that
sweet spot for left-handed hitter down
and in and the other one was a 92 mile
an hour fastball over the plate he just
spanked in the other direction so in
terms of the pitching though could was
he playing rope-a-dope in the spring I
mean what you know this is what scared
me what scared me about him was this was
you would expect like a young guy that
go to his first spring training camp
whether he's from Japan brothers from
Latin America wherever you're from
you're thinking you're getting your
first test so for him there was going to
be some nerves involved and if anything
you'd see him maybe overthrowing or you
know you could see it's simply a case of
nerves I've guided I watched in the
Cactus League I was like I didn't see
any 98 to 100 I didn't see the good
split finger I I didn't see anything
that I saw in that first start against
the Oakland A's maybe on the backfields
they saw that but but I know this there
were like four days before the season
end reach and there were a lot of people
in the industry maybe not in the Angels
camp that thought this guy was better
off served starting the year in the
minor leagues in double or triple a so
well that those people that made that
statement they're kind of having to take
that back right now because he looked
really impressive on the mound I don't
know if he's going to be able to hit
enough a lot of people think that he is
my expertise isn't hitting but for what
I've seen on the mound rich I like what
I saw in terms of starting I mean he
started 14 games in 18 years Dan I mean
being able to start and hit
like this I can't even imagine right
right it's amazing mmm so let's let's
let's move on to the unwritten rules of
baseball that reared its ugly head
already I mean I couldn't believe what
you think of the twins having a problem
with that kid
sisqó of the Orioles bunting against the
the shift down 7 this is my this is my
feeling toward it I the unwritten rules
the the game is you and I knew it as
kids in the 70s the 80s the Red Sox and
the Yankees there was no love loss you
know what I mean that there dis rivalry
all you got to do is turn on a game
tonight flip on any game that starts
locally in your area and you're gonna
see five or six guys from each team
hugging it out before the game in
centerfield right so you can forget
about Bucky Dent and the bad sides the
Royals and the Yankees and hal mcgrae
going in and taking will he ran off and
throwing him out to left field that's
gone this is the way I look at it
nowadays if the twins were so upset then
what the hell are they doing playing the
shift up by seven runs in the ninth
inning right that's the way I look at it
if you're trying to take away part of
his game and you're gonna play the shift
in a seven nothing lead if you're gonna
give him the entire left side of the
infield to just go ahead and get a bunt
down why not take it that's the way I
look at it and then and the problem I
have about it too is the Dozier who I
love I've never met him I haven't
interviewed him but I just love his game
he's one of those guys that could play
for me right I mean I just love
everything about about him and his style
he was the one who was basically saying
you know I was gonna say something when
he came to second base but I know the
Orioles have their own veterans to
handle it
he stole a second in the ninth inning of
a freezing-cold game up for yesterday I
mean I know isn't that this isn't that
in the same area code rich and that's
why I'm saying you kind of have to take
with a grain of salt what you see from
players nowadays because this this isn't
red sox-yankees in the 60s and 70s it's
a different game and I don't even know
what the hell the unwritten rules are
anymore when do you when do you call off
the dogs when don't you bunt when don't
you hit and run you have some teams that
are down seven or eight runs and they're
stealing and teams are getting mad but
we're seeing teams score seven eight
runs at will now it's a different game
right now rich and I don't know
I listen I'm with you III had a chance
that we do it 30 teams in 30 days I had
a day I spent with the twins camp I came
away just so impressed with not only the
twins but Dozier I think he is a
terrific terrific guy and I don't know
if he got caught in up in the moment
that maybe a guy had a chance at a no
enter a shutout whatever was that was
his way of sticking up or maybe maybe
quite honestly he didn't have time to
really stop and think about like wait a
minute we're shifting and we're up by
seven runs maybe he didn't enter that
into the equation when he saw that work
you know what I mean the microphone was
stuck into his face right after a game
was over and you know maybe he didn't
have time to sit back and say hey Wow
well we're still shifting with the 7-run
lead so I guess it's it's all fair it
really is a couple more minutes left
with Dan please sack of MLB Network and
MLB tonight here on the Rich Eisen show
what are the relievers in Philadelphia
thinking right now Dan good boy that you
know what I was you know I kind of I had
a kind of a front-row seat to this
because I was in Clearwater as a week as
a guest instructor with the Phillies and
it's it's a it's a total organization
that is it's a total City there are some
places rich where you buy into these
analytics and bullpen ting and we're
going to we're going to do something
different it's really hard to do that in
Philadelphia because this is the city
we're talking like Larry Bowa Charlie
Manuel Dallas Green if there was ever a
blue collar let's keep you know you
don't mean like this new wave of
baseball it took a long time for it to
infiltrate into South Philadelphia and I
think there are a lot of people in the
media there are a lot of people in
Philadelphia that are loving this kind
of crash right now because I think when
you think of the Phillies you think of
this bruising organization in the 80s
and Greg luzinski and Mike Schmidt Pete
Rose and Chase Utley and Ryan Howard and
Jimmy Rollins and and it's a tough pill
for them to swallow with that said I
mean it was a mistake not having anybody
up you come out there but i but i but
sometimes i think young managers you're
trying to I think Gabe might be guilty
of trying to put out too many fires at
one time rich you know what I mean like
these
trying to infiltrate this whole new way
of looking at people looking at the
system the game of analytics bull
penning usage and I just found it the
the only thing that I really I guess
it's easy to we could sit a thousand
miles away and critique a manager
critique a coach but on the opening day
Aaron Ola was thrown the ball so well
and if there's one guy on that team that
you can trust to go out there and give
you innings and I really thought it gave
the Braves a shot to get back into the
game and they'll all they took him out
of it yes Hey look what we saw we saw it
with Dave Roberts in the world frickin
Series last year with Rich Hill like
stuck in this bullpen well where's the
feel where's the feel and obviously
we're again we're just one weekend and I
understand but it just strikes me that
have we reached a point in time that
managers who are of the new generation
where it's all about we well relievers
are better in the sixth and seventh
because the starters isn't very good
third time around blah blah blah blah
blah have we reached the point where
there's no field no field zero field
yeah but you know you listen press me
and I wasn't sure I wasn't probably as
shocked as you were in everybody
industry I'm a big Aaron Boone slam I
tell you what I lied you know when you
sit in you watch I watch the game
yesterday by the way Louis Severino he
might be the most improved starting
pitcher in baseball right now written
this guy if there was an ace he's an ace
there are a lot of teams everybody says
oh man we've got an ace that is an ace
in the makings right now Louis Severino
was dominant but getting back to Aaron
Boone he's got a great feel of analytics
with the players but yet he's got a
great feel of trusting his gut he's got
a great pitching coat than Larry
Rothschild I was shocked at the hire but
after I've seen it I can understand why
now because this guy he's really good
rich a grandiy he has a lot better
personnel to work with and gabe kapler
does in Philadelphia but I'm really
liking there and Boone right now a lot
that's great higher I know I know
already though he was in hot water
because he went to Betances for a second
inning
and and Dave Robertson he walked Josh
donald's it's just it's just outs and
hurt like significant I don't know if
he's hurt significantly but I think he's
hurt enough right now he's not close to
a hundred percent to where he's one of
the top players in the game anymore
right now he's got some issues with that
shoulder he played in the field last
night against the White Sox he had three
attempts he he made all three plays but
something's just not quite right with
him still a really good player he needs
to get healthy all right Dan
appreciate the time as always and and
calling once again maybe you'll be in
Augusta
you got it sounds good there's Dan
please sack here on the show Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience